unas cifras decepcionantes frente al
desempleo eeuu presentó los números de
empleo del mes de septiembre pero no
cumplieron las expectativas la pandemia
con el incremento de casos de la
variante delta es uno de los factores
que impide la mejora que esperaban los
estadounidenses la oferta y demanda de
empleos sigue desequilibrada parece que
esos problemas de oferta de mano de obra
no se han resuelto por sí mismos parece
que los trabajadores todavía están
luchando por salir y conseguir trabajo y
los empleadores todavía están luchando
por encontrar los trabajadores que
necesitan las empresas agregaron sólo
194 mil empleos en septiembre la mitad
de lo que habían pronosticado los
economistas con 500 mil puestos de
trabajo este desbalance no fue subrayado
por el presidente de byd en quien
prefiere fijarse en las cifras del
desempleo que suenan más optimistas
sídney hoy por primera vez desde marzo
de 2020 la tasa de desempleo
estadounidense está por debajo del 5%
en sólo ocho meses desde que asumí la
presidencia en medio de una grave crisis
de salud pública y económica la tasa de
desempleo está ahora por debajo del 5%
al 4.8 por ciento e impulsar los datos
de desempleo antes de la pandemia eran
del 35 % los 7 millones 700.000
desempleados estadounidenses tendrán que
esperar a que la economía siga mejorando
en los próximos meses a medida que
disminuyen las infecciones por hobby 19
y las personas realmente en la búsqueda
de trabajo